foreign
I think I know why you're excited the
midterm elections are upon us they are
11 days away
I guess I was wrong not excited about
that but they are
well I don't blame you for being a
little apathetic I mean wow what an
election this is the Republicans are
putting up a slate of election deniers
and Oaths and crackpots and Crooks
[Laughter]
and the Democrats uh have a guy who
recently died of a stroke so
we're not making fun but you saw that
debate in Pennsylvania The Dr Oz against
John fetterman uh he did recently have a
stroke uh fetterman and he is still a
little shaky uh that debate oh a
neurologists call that condition
Herschel Walker
[Applause]
I like it oh Herschel Walker another one
I cannot keep up with this guy another
woman came forward to say that he paid
for an abortion this guy has provided
more abortions than planned parenthood
is that one of the popular costumes now
for kids in Georgia is that the kids go
out with a ghost costume and a sign that
says Herschel paid for this
[Applause]
uh but that well that was or hopefully
still is a big issue in the election
abortion
nothing this crowd is nothing gets this
run okay well there in America I'm
telling you it's a big issue came up in
the uh fetterman debate Dr Oz set about
abortion it should be something is
decided between a doctor a woman and
local political leaders
well this is going to be new for women
[Laughter]
the mayor's office yeah listen
to my period
um
yes I'll hold
but the big news and uh the uh Tech
World Elon Musk has now taken over
Twitter
and probably will put Trump back on it
uh Trump said yesterday he said Twitter
now he says is insane hands but that's
also what he said when Kanye bought a
school so
[Applause]